en las capitales europeas la bicicleta
eléctrica se ha convertido en un medio
de transporte por derecho propio
una cuarta parte no se fabrica en china
sino en portugal aquí en el sur de
oporto la empresa univalle es totalmente
nueva la región alberga más de 60
plantas de montaje como ésta
sergio lleva 20 años trabajando en el
sector de la bicicleta es la primera vez
que ve una explosión en la demanda de
estas dimensiones
bueno la actividad
aumentó mucho debido a la pandemia y
debido a la conciencia de las personas
de tener que usar medios de transporte
sostenible
nosotros hemos contratado
el doble de personas que teníamos antes
y ahora estamos en unas 100 personas
este crecimiento es tan rápido que
encontrar personal cualificado se ha
convertido en un reto buenos días o nada
buenos días cuánto tiempo llevas cinco
meses
al haber terminado su último contrato en
medio de la pandemia
anna temía quedarse sin trabajo
pensé que demoraría más fue rápido envió
un currículo
a los dos días tres días me llamaron
para hacer la entrevista presencial
viene la entrevista y cuestión de dos
días ya me dijeron me avisaron para para
comenzar
desde 2019 portugal es el primer
fabricante de bicicletas de europa el
país produce unas 3 millones de
bicicletas al año y en este taller se
pintan 170 mil de ellas anualmente
el crecimiento es tal que para paula la
hija de sergio tomar las riendas del
negocio familiar es una opción obvia
el 22 ya está cerrado de la capacidad
productiva el año 2023 parte de él
también entonces es un negocio y un
sector que tiene siempre futuro las dos
ruedas
que está creciendo cada vez más
el año pasado se abrió una nueva fábrica
a sólo 20 km es la única en europa que
fabrica cuadros de bicicleta
aquí es donde empieza todo estos son los
tubos de aluminio que utilizamos toda
nuestra materia prima viene de portugal
100 local que es la razón misma de la
creación de esta empresa
fue por petición de los clientes
europeos nos preguntaron por qué no
hacíamos nuestras propias monturas
porque todo solía venir 100% de asia y
así fue como empezamos la industria de
la bicicleta regresa a suelo europeo
esta fábrica se está centrando en la
robotización para satisfacer la
creciente demanda del sector este
edificio costó 30 millones de euros
con esta calidad con todas estas
tecnologías con un plazo de entrega más
corto si somos competitivos y somos
capaces de competir con cualquier país
del mundo
esta tecnología permite al sector
competir con china taiwán y malasia
además existe la ventaja de la
proximidad
todo se hace en portugal incluida la
homologación de los distintos modelos y
tiene
nos garantizamos la calidad de los
productos para que confiables antes de
su comercialización
de bebés como es probidad la federación
de vehículos de dos ruedas cree que el
éxito de la región se debe en gran
medida a los impuestos que la unión
europea impuso a china en la década de
se han puesto medidas de antidoping
porque la mano de obra china es mucho
más barata porque no tiene costes de
seguridad social etcétera
según este economista el país no está
cosechando todos los beneficios de los
progresos realizados por la industria
para que portugal se haga tan famoso con
las bicicletas como alemania con los
coches necesitaríamos nuestras propias
marcas lamentablemente no somos un
fabricante propiamente dicho y la
mayoría de las veces producimos para
diferentes marcas europeas son los que
más ganan así que el valor añadido de la
industria que es bueno pero podría ser
mejor una plusvalía realizada por sus
vecinos europeos portugal trabaja en un
90% para las marcas extranjeras